at
0 party
today drag
[Music]
and if we give physical time
now it
's like that that's why you're from frank
america min
neighborhoods of 4
geither raid band
around here
if there's confusion
even though they didn't stop it
's winning
in my tennis
in question
that's why you have to  to be
twice
pass
the key 7 token
line to subscribe
to this date
[Music]
oh
and to close
9 to
have montes bernstein
massa
not
for this decade
[Music]
kenya
efe
even the theme
aucas
not with the 'tie break'
that is to say
mensah mail
my cut
[Music]
in that aspect
sung
and
general for it
was part of the misfortune of before it
dug further faster
to me
not
what has to come
yes
[Music]
to karina and you use
since luck
in and flat in
love
me the safe
the face
go well
better
thanks
ah
I just saw sex
cat
that today's crisis
grow
nothing
ah
[Music]
[Applause]
ok
in euskadi
wow
that is katana
[Music]
georgia
and
have
max
sana of science
but no  so  zero
were 6
no
if it is strong it is inflated
in explaining
how dark it is
and you
know
[Music]
how about it